[Music]
well speaking of retards
uh joey diaz talks about brendan's shop
not know what was going on with
brian callan and and
bobby lee and all these guys i had no
idea guys honest to god by the way this
person who clipped this is two buttons
fyi for all you guys that wrote me
little [ __ ] side notes
that brendan was a [ __ ] worm and all
this because me and john bernthal were
talking about him listen guys
i i don't know what's going on i don't
know who hits on who
i don't know what's said up there
anymore like i said
before we even start this conversation
mental health is [ __ ] king so
i don't know what happened i realized
mike kind of told me i know that after i
did the podcast
with john i thought everything was fine
there was no [ __ ] you know and all of
a sudden two days later people like joey
i think you're wrong about brendan he's
a and chooch he's this he's that and i
was like i have to bleep it yeah because
this channel's uh when you put these
clips up and they're monetized the first
one minute can't have any curses in her
you can't monetize them well good i'm
glad that this person made 11 bucks to
make a bad video no i think that that's
how he uploaded it to youtube joey diaz
oh oh yeah
probably clipped it like that guys
listen
i know the dude he's a student of comedy
he's the student brendan schaub
is when does he stop being a student
though when does he graduate
[Laughter]
by the way if he's a student he's riding
the little short bus okay
uh students usually get showtime
specials no but a lot of students drop
out
he works hard
working hard i know he works hard
sure
working hard doesn't mean that you get
to be have a showtime special though
it's like saying somebody works hard
that's like a compliment you give to
somebody that's not necessarily good at
their job right
they just work hard
it's like if you're [ __ ] and you
work really hard to get these
versus somebody who's maybe don't work
work as hard but they get b's it's like
you know you the compliment the go-to
compliment is he works really hard it's
like well okay
he's trying
yeah
not everyone knows how to do everything
there's other things yeah driving is not
the only thing
i i have not it's like i haven't been
around brendan for 18 months but when
you open up the computer
you see you know when you go on youtube
to get music or whatever there's always
a one
brendan this brendan special truly poppy
brendan this i said i don't even know
what i can say anymore i don't even know
you know i watch the special it's on
youtube i watched like 15 minutes of it
it's brandon okay cool so you watched
almost all of it
my
god that is the most telling statement
yup of how bad brendan schaub is yeah i
don't know i watched like 15 minutes of
it and yeah brent that's brendan he so
wait he's definitely on the screen he
couldn't be bothered to watch his friend
who's a student in the games entire 23
minutes of the special he only got to 15
and stopped so it was so bad your 15 is
padded you've watched eight minutes of
it yeah
is it [ __ ] hysterical
no
but
oh no
oh no
oh god the cracks are forming oh this is
good oh is this a defensive
brandon schwab again la's falling apart
because because you're about to hear
that he but he's a nice guy you ready
because we haven't heard the second part
of this let's see but it's funny
he has some no no no no no no
we got to hear that again rip reverse
reverse reverse you say i don't even
know what that can say anymore i don't
even know you know i watched the special
it's on youtube
i watched like it i called no but i mean
it was a [ __ ] what's it minutes of it
it's brendan
is it [ __ ] hysterical
yeah no
but it's funny but it's funny
but it's funny
yeah
it's interesting i said it's special
[Laughter]
he has some great [ __ ] things it's
like any other special i can watch on i
would rather watch tim robinson in real
life clean his gutters
then that would be way more fun
brendan's job doing comedy
netflix or any other [ __ ] thing i
mean okay it's outstanding to [ __ ]
like ride me and hold on hold on hold on
did joey diaz just say that brendan
schwab's special is just like any other
special on netflix
joey dave chappelle's on netflix
ricky i just saw ricky gervais special
which by the way [ __ ] hilarious is on
this it's on netflix can i ask you a
question sure if it's like on par with
all this stuff on netflix yeah uh why is
it on netflix because he sucks i just
thought you know he sucks
can watch on netflix or any other
[ __ ] thing i mean okay it's
outstanding to [ __ ] like rodney and
all those mothers cuz no but brendan's
doing okay it's not even open mic good
do you understand that merch and i sat
there and did a comedy fight club with
some really green open mic people all
right and they were still way funnier
than anything on that special
hilarious no but i was good funny
going on him hitting on bobby lee's
girlfriend bobby's girl i don't know any
about that thing all i know is what his
character shows me when i open up he
started thick boy he does a food diary
he started a clothing line he's [ __ ]
trying if you don't like him yeah puff
daddy has a clothing line but i wouldn't
want to watch him do stand up none of
those things that he mentioned are
character traits no no those are just
things he did those are called
businesses i believe that's just a thing
that he did like yeah he's got good
character like he takes a [ __ ] in the
morning and like he drinks coffee
that's not
he sells things on the internet he's a
good father he's a good father don't pay
don't buy the shirts
if you don't like it don't but for you
[ __ ] to sit there constantly
constantly
and tear into that i don't even know who
the [ __ ] it is
oh i know who it is it's called let me
look it up here the internet
you're making it he's making it seem
dude that special doesn't have 67 000
down votes last i checked
because
because
there's a little group of people that
are trying to take him down okay
uh what what was the name of the special
again
the gringo poppy
i and go poppy brandon shop
i think i'm already looking it up uh 145
000 downloads down votes okay
by the way the real heroes are the
people that made the the plug-in for
chrome so we could still see the
dislikes which means
145 000 people downvoted something even
knowing that most people aren't gonna
see the down vote
right i mean just to tell you how bad it
is okay that's true the down votes count
more now than ever yeah because that
means that most people don't even aren't
going to see that as 145 000 dislikes
absolutely he's not you don't think he
knows that you don't think he's heard
that
but heard what that he sucks sorry let
me back up
and tear into this i don't even know who
the [ __ ] it is i don't even know what
his tears into him constantly he's not
you don't think he knows that you don't
think he's heard that you don't think he
knows that he's not funny no i don't
think he knows that
but you know what i give him credit
because after all the [ __ ] everybody
says
he still shows up
oh well that's great that's great hey
you know what he shows up hey you know
what let me tell you something
i don't care that that quarterback threw
eight interceptions last game all right
because he shows up to every single game
he's there because when you're looking
for really good like you know what you
know why i liked carlin
because he showed up
he was there really i think that's what
most people appreciated about carlin the
most
he showed up
richard pryor showed up he was late
but he showed up yeah well you know
crack will do that
he still shows up how many people would
show up would you show up a viewer from
brendan no because i'd get the hint
[Laughter]
all right nobody wants to see me i got
it all right i'll stick to the food
truck thing
bro yeah go do your future thing do an
mma show nobody would care right
well actually no they would because he
also knows so little about mma it's
[ __ ] mind-blowing brain injury it's
mind-blowing how little he knows about
the sport he came from
with all the [ __ ] against you still
shows up to the comedy store
have you guys seen the imdb page for a
special mm-hmm
oh yeah what wait wait what's it at now
what what's the go to show links it's
there
is it still uh that they still leave all
the cast members and stuff on there the
prank ones
oh i don't know if they left them on
there because i did see that
that was very funny i think they cleaned
it up but there was a are really funny
all right
oh with 3
400 ratings it has 1.1 out of 10. well
that's good that's a good that's it's
not zero
editorial department chinsuyi
guy in the back with the websites
yeah they do still still have a [ __ ]
fake cast on it
oh no
shows up to all these places whether
he's good or not somebody's paying 25 to
go see him
right or wrong i mean somebody's paying
the money to go see him so what do you
for all these shows that he's selling
out are you people going to see if
what's the chick that died from the ods
i don't know man there's so many in la i
i couldn't tell you the specific one
you're talking about
okay
yeah i don't know elijah's lesson oh no
that's one that's going to i can't keep
up
yeah i went to rehab no no no whatever
amy winehouse
natalie whatever i don't know natalie
winehouse yeah natalie whatever
on the goofs page for the imdb jam
his comedy special was filmed over five
different performances in front of a
small crowd by an amateur crew
25 minutes was i'm sorry was the best
of five shows did he dress the same
there's continuity errors in it there's
an audience member look an audience
member wearing a yellow t-shirt is seen
enthusiastically clapping and laughing
but in the next shot is motionless
they had to [ __ ] film it multiple
times
did he really would did he wear the same
clothes is that what happened
dude i think they tried to like
cover that up a little bit
there's an added laugh track
that i believe by the way what
that i do believe is the added laugh
track clashes with the actual audience
room mics the sparse laughter on the
original audio occasionally peaks the
microphone preamps and you can hear the
distortion
no no i'm talking guadalajara
born and raised
every night
i've never been thicker since i got with
a mexican man
i think with three [ __ ] c's
dude everything they eat bean cheese
bean cheese bean cheese bean she's like
what the hell man we're gonna carb load
year round
we never tailor off the carbs that's a
game plan
is that a joke you know i want to go to
yes vergie that was a joke
rehabs
that girl at the end she was selling our
shows people were like oh she passed out
well guess what if she sold five
thousand tickets
four thousand tickets he have to make
people should we
sounds all the time his mouth is very
wet
dude joey diaz's mouth is just a
symphony of unpleasant sounds
all the time went to see the train wreck
do you know that i mean
so you're saying people wait wait wait
wait he's saying people want to see amy
whitehouse could people want to see the
train wreck so you're saying that people
are going to go see the brendan shop
train wreck are you not helping your own
point here joey no guess what if she
sold 5 000 tickets
4 000 tickets
were people who went to see the train
wreck sounds like lou paterno talking
do you know that i mean
and it's [ __ ] scary to say that a guy
like me would pay 45 bucks
or 50 bucks or 60 bucks to go there with
my heart oh she's going to be different
she's not going to shoot heroin today
you know she's not going to drink an 18
cup what does this have to do with
burning shrub i'm trying to keep up here
dale's she's not going to do 30 xanax
i'll be fine i'm joey diaz i'm going to
go see whatever her [ __ ] what's her name
wine house
he's cuz
you fake cuban mobster
amy one house with a [ __ ] up feet
because you know how she had stinky toes
every time i see her shoes and [ __ ] i'm
like that [ __ ] got those english stinky
little toes and [ __ ]
i love it
yeah
that though she could sing but would i
pay 50 bucks to go see a train wreck
yes
yes yes yes i'd probably pay more if i
knew it was going to be a train wreck
again joey i get that he's your friend
but here's the problem the problem is is
people still cheering them on
you know was he funny you know it wasn't
funny either you're lying and that's
what really starts to bug me it's how
much they just [ __ ] lie about
brendan's shop you suck brendan shop
[ __ ] sucks and by the way comics it's
okay to say that
no it's not not if you're in l.a man
who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]